have MGM convinced Amazon that a
Stargate TV series is more preferable
than a movie could Amazon have changed
their
minds we know how the meeting went
welcome to citri your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie
[Music]
Channel so nearly a month ago now there
was a meeting at Amazon Prime Studios
over at Culver City their main
headquarters where Jennifer S and a few
other of the higher up Executives over
Amazon Prime invited a couple of people
from MGM plus and MGM wider Community to
come and basically explain to them why
MGM is so convinced that Stargate should
be a TV series before a movie I told you
that in this meeting MGM put forwards
their Five-Year Plan that plan would
basically be to switch the movie into a
miniseries to then do a Prime series
that would run for at least three
seasons over a fiveyear period and then
do three individual Standalone Series in
between those followed up by and having
basically conclusion of a fiveyear phase
with some kind of movie whether that
would be cinematic or straight to
streaming now in that meeting MGM
weren't arguing about storylines they
weren't telling Amazon what they thought
the story should be they were talking
about a format the way the story should
be told because at the end of the day
whoever then gets brought in to write
create develop this series they're the
ones that will then tell us how The
Story Goes not Executives over
MGM so at the time I didn't know much
about how this meeting went but thanks
to a source I haven't been able to speak
to in a ages that has quite a unique
perspective on lots of these things
going on particularly over at the MGM
side I was able to find out a little bit
more the truth on this one is and you
can turn the video off now if you want
to but and I wouldn't blame you too much
the truth of the matter is there doesn't
seem to have actually been a final
decision made again so how did the
meeting actually go first of all well
MGM brought a bunch of demographics and
one of the things they were really
focusing on was the growth of MGM plus
and this is actually an exclusive the
mgm's production cost for MGM plus has
being increased by 25% by Amazon in the
last few weeks so for their budget 2024
to 2025 is seeing a 25% increase on the
previous year that is clearly
significant and shows Amazon really are
planning to push MGM plus forwards as
its own platform its own streaming
service particularly in in the United
States where it sees very significant
growth over the next 5 years this may
lead into a plan that Amazon has in
regards to they want Amazon Prime to
really be a hub where lots of other
streaming platforms are delivered to the
customer they don't necessarily want
Amazon Prime to be the primary place
they put the television shows they want
it to be on all of these different
platforms underneath it and then they
may end up offering us an Amazon Prime
Plus Package where you can pay one price
and get all of those streaming channels
in one thing and that might even include
things like Disney plus if Amazon get
their way and get the deal they want
that is Amazon's long-term plan for the
platform so increasing the popularity
and putting shows like Stargate on MGM
plus is really part of the long-term
strategy for the overall platform and
the executives from from MGM including
Mike right who's head of MGM plus were
arguing this point very hard with the
Amazon Executives they were basically
saying if you want to push the growth of
MGM plus we need a show like Stargate
they had a bunch of data that been
generated over the last two years about
the interest in shows like Stargate and
how much it actually could push the
growth of what they consider to be a
smaller platform like MGM plus the
argument was if we can keep the cost of
MGM plus under $10 or five or six pounds
here in the UK but we can put really big
shows on like Stargate including all of
the previous stuff you know Stargate sg1
SGU SGA as well as films from MGM which
is another big point that they're
arguing for that actually MGM plus is
going to start getting more movies uh
internationally as well as in the United
States over the next 12 months or so
that then MGM could almost double in
size over the next 8 18 months to two
years now at the moment they haven't got
a massive Bedrock of subscribers but
anything that doubles over that smaller
period would be considered a massive
success for the business another big
part of their argument though is
actually that the sort of people that
they have been told would pay for
something like MGM plus and pay for
something like Stargate is the slightly
older demographic it is the 30 plus
demographic they're the people that are
going to want to watch MGM for old MGM
movies for example so they're saying a
show like Stargate where the demographic
does tend to be a little older on
average for people that report they want
to watch this show which makes sense
because anybody born under the age of 15
didn't exist when the show was on our
screens actually means that it would fit
perfectly in the overall idea for what
MGM plus wants to be in the long term
anyway
so two major arguments there we need a
show like this to grow and more
importantly a show like this would
actually fit in what we're trying to do
on the whole anyway MGM plus Executives
also did talk about budget they did say
that they believe a Stargate show could
be done in an around the budget of
something like Billy the Kid which is
currently I believe three or4 million an
episode they were talking about lots of
ways that they would basically mirror
what sg1 did they might have one
reasonably big star I would personally
consider Richard Anderson a freaking
Legend but he was never really an A-list
he's not a movie star but you would want
somebody that is sort of an A-list TV
star and then the rest of the cast would
be a bunch of people you have never
heard of but they would work very hard
to make sure that the casting was
absolutely spot on there would be actors
that you won't know but we will fall in
love with very quickly by following the
basic model of sg1 by keeping the budget
reasonably small this is a show that
they were arguing would fit perfectly
onto MGM plus and actually be a catalyst
for growth over several years hence how
they do a five-year phased plan they had
a further argument however to say to
increase the popularity of Stargate
overall because
internationally MGM plus really isn't
watched by anybody in America it has a
reasonably good base of of subscribers
but worldwide no so they were arguing
that even though they should have MGM
Plus in the United States the rest of
the world it should be on Prime the
argument for this was twofold obviously
increase the Homegrown MGM plus
label but increase the popularity of the
show and make it more sustainable over
that 5-year period by offering it the
wider audience internationally on Prime
now now how would they do that it would
go to MGM plus first and it would go on
Prime about a week later that is
generally what MGM were proposing but
what did Amazon think well the Amazon
executive did not give the MGM
Executives an answer there and then they
listened they said thank you very much
and then there have been a few meetings
since but my source is reasonably close
to MGM Plus's head CEO Michael Wright
and apparently in his opinion Amazon is
still prioritizing the Cinematic movie
but the argument did get through and
they seem to think that a TV show is
significantly more likely now than it
was six weeks ago how does this affect
all of it with Stargate returning well
it causes more problems to be honest
because it causes more doubt if Amazon
Executives were confident about a
Stargate return and just doing the movie
I think it would have been announced or
at very least it'll be announced in the
next couple of weeks if they're not sure
and then they've got MGM Executives
coming in going we've got this other
idea and we can back it up with evidence
and apparently it was slideshow after
slideshow after slideshow of like
questionnaire results and blah blah blah
then that does throw in doubt in a
period in Hollywood where there's a lot
of Doubt anyway nobody really knows what
the cinemas are going to do nobody
really knows what movies do well at the
cinema and what won't nobody really
knows what TV shows are going to succeed
and what won't so it's a very strange
time for the studios but
Amazon right now they are focusing on
getting all of the projects that they
had going already before the strikes
back up and running that is going to be
the main focus they've got to get all of
those things that are halfway through
filming or about to start filming or
whatever back up and running that's
going to take a little bit of time and
then they will make a decision on things
like Stargate and then they will focus
on new projects and I'm not just talking
about Stargate there I'm talking about
several other things with MGM as well
including RoboCop Etc because you have
to remember as well
MGM on the whole really doesn't exist
anymore it has been completely absorbed
by Amazon what's left of MGM has been
completely restructured but MGM will be
doing several projects like RoboCop Etc
but my understanding is Stargate has
been taken on by Amazon and it will be
far more an Amazon decision and
production of what they consider to be
one of the main franchises that they
spent all of that money on buying from
MGM we just have to be a little more
patient however irritating that is but
guys get into the comments tell me what
you think I know a lot of you are
getting very bored by all of this and to
be honest me being able to see behind
the curtain of Amazon is frustrating
because we get to see how indecisive
they seem to be but they are planning to
spend at least $100 million on the first
season of this or $200 million on a
movie and that's not a small investment
so I suppose they should really take
their time and we do want it done
properly don't we
yeah we want it done properly but what
do you think get into the comments and
tell me do you actually think we're
going to get an announcement this year I
think we will but what you Sid trekers
think is what matters so get into the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com sidre
where most of our new videos Premier
first and you get to see them without
the adverts and you get a free gift
after three months also go to c.g. which
is our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our videos and
we try to add a little bit more detail
for you to digest go and check it out as
always please stay safe and I see you
next
[Music]
time